views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
as many of you know i have not been
quiet about my urgent desire to see
children return to
in-person learning on politics now
education
jobs green energy we break down plans
outlined by governor sisilak in his
state of the state speech
plus republicans are pushing a slate of
new bills
to restore electoral confidence in the
silver state democratic process
election security and checks and
balances priorities from the republicans
ahead of the legislative session and
i'm anna wernicke in washington today
president biden took the oath of office
in a ceremony that made history i'll
have those details coming up
from eight news now this is politics now
with your host john langler
we are heading towards the 2021
legislative session
this week governor steve sissellach gave
his state of the state address outlining
his vision for nevada
his budget is only about a 2 percent cut
from the one approved in 2019
deeper cuts were expected the proposed
budget also empties out the 97.5
million dollars in the state's rainy day
fund the biggest
increase its medicaid spending it would
go up in the governor's budget by 1.6
billion dollars to cover
a nearly 19 percent increase in caseload
the governor also touted what he calls
his economic action plan featuring a
green
jobs program i will work with senator
chris brooks
and the legislature to pass a bold
energy bill
establishing our commitment to increase
transmission
storage and distribution of all forms of
clean energy
more importantly passing this bill will
create good paying construction jobs
starting this year and helping in our
fight against climate change
this bill will attract and develop a
variety of new industries
including electric vehicle
infrastructure component manufacturing
in lithium mining governor sysolak
also added his plan includes job
retraining programs
and on the jobs front he also called for
upgrading nevada's beleaguered
unemployment system
he acknowledged that it is overwhelmed
out of date and needs to be fixed
our computer infrastructure is still
outdated and our systems can be improved
i'm recommending to the legislature that
we work together
to modernize and utilize private sector
expertise to help nevadans in need
more broadly we need to recover the
federal funding dollars
that rightfully belong to nevadans my
goal is to increase nevada's share of
federal grants by a hundred million
dollars over the next two years
and by 500 million annually by twenty
twenty six
governor sysolak also wants to use
federal dollars to upgrade
other outdated state systems he says his
job plan will create
thirty thousand short-term jobs 170 000
construction and development jobs
and 165 000 permanent jobs
another major issue in the governor's
budget and the upcoming legislative
session has to do with education
that was a key part of the governor's
campaign he says distance learning is
only making school harder particularly
for disadvantaged students
as many of you know i have not been
quiet about my urgent desire to see
children return to in-person learning
because we will not recover as a state
if we leave our children behind
i will do whatever it takes to get our
students back in the classroom
that's why we've worked to supply ppe
ensure rapid testing was made available
to all school districts
and now prioritize our educators for
vaccines
alright so here is how the education
budget would break out
nevada according to the governor nevada
actually has 330 million dollars
less for 2021 to 2023 that school budget
however
state officials plan to put 450 million
dollars in federal cares act funding
towards education so that gives them an
extra 130
million dollars extra compared to this
year
meanwhile the republican rebuttal to the
governor's state of the state was given
by assembly caucus leader dr robin titus
in her speech she thanked first
responders and others for their efforts
during the pandemic
but dr titus does not want to see more
shutdowns without republican input
checks and balances among the three
branches of the government are essential
for transparent and collaborative
government
unilateral laws that bypass legislative
bodies
create restrictive policies that only
further damage our already struggling
economy
dr titus also says republicans plan to
propose a series of election security
bills
modeled after similar legislation in
florida
the budget and party jockeying it all
leads up to the start of the 2021
legislative session
and we now know how lawmakers are going
to get their business done
at the start only lawmakers essential
staff and a few journalists will be
allowed inside the capitol building
the public has to watch the hearings
online and submit their comments on
zoom lawmakers will also not be allowed
to bring friends or family in the
building again because of the pandemic
the legislative building will be open
for the public again
after all lawmakers and staff get their
covet 19 vaccination
however to participate in a committee
hearing in person you have to show a
covet 19 vaccination card or take a
rapid covert test yourself
the session starts february first in
washington d.c
a change in the white house joe biden is
now the 46th president of the united
states he was inaugurated on wednesday
he took the oath of office in a
historical ceremony marked by more
security and fewer people
anna wernicke was there a historic day
here in washington joe biden addressed
the nation for the first time
as president calling for unity in what
he says is one of the country's
most challenging times joe biden
now president biden hi joseph robinette
biden jr do solemnly swear
biden took the oath of office on the
west steps of the u.s capitol
becoming the 46th president of the
united states
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity the ceremony kept with
tradition but was unlike any
inauguration in history
overlooking an almost empty national
mall in a city
locked down over threats of domestic
violence we must end this
uncivil war that pits red against blue
rural versus urban conservative versus
liberal
we can do this if we open our souls
instead of hardening our hearts
president biden says today
americans can be hopeful nodding to his
second in command
vice president kamala harris the first
woman
and woman of color elected to national
office
don't tell me things can't change the
small audience included former
presidents barack obama
george w bush and bill clinton
noticeably absent
former president donald trump have a
good life
we will see you soon who wish the new
administration luck
and thanked the nation before departing
for florida
back on the capitol steps president
biden said it's time for a new beginning
we will get through this together
together president biden participated in
many of the inaugural traditions
including the pass in review where the
new president assesses the military
before returning to the white house for
an evening of virtual performances
in washington i'm anna warnicky back to
you
busy week in washington there was the
inauguration on wednesday alexander
limon joins us now to talk
about the very busy week so let's start
quickly to by talking about inauguration
day there were concerns about security
in the capitol
there was a lot of national guardsmen
and women in there uh
just how did everything turn out on
wednesday where the what's the sense in
washington
yeah the sense is that from a security
standpoint it was
a total success things went very
smoothly there were no problems reported
but it did take a lot to get to that
point i mean
you know that there were 25 000 members
of the national guard deployed to the
immediate area around the white house
and the capital
in addition that was completely shut off
to the public
by fencing and then in addition to that
you know the
the roads and bridges and highways
coming into the city many of them
were shut down um so access was very
limited
into the city um and it was a bit odd i
mean the night before the inauguration
um
i was staying at a hotel just to be sure
that i could get to the inauguration
in time and that i wouldn't have any
delays due to the security and you know
you could just see
so many armed members of the national
guard patrolling out in the streets
it's kind of an unusual sight in the
capital
particularly you know in the context of
as we were preparing for the transfer of
power
power has now transitioned to the biden
administration now let's get down to
business here
just like the administration is trying
to what are the big topics what are the
big
things on the agenda that have to get
dealt with first cobit 19 there's no
doubt about that president joe biden and
his team have made it very clear that
that is their
top priority um trying to get the
infections
under control and also dealing with the
economic fallout of the pandemic
um so we saw very quickly president joe
biden signed
a series of various executive orders to
try to deal with that dealing with
everything from
invoking the defense production act to
produce
more ppe and also really trying to
deal with this issue of the vaccine roll
out
and that was alexander limon from
washington d.c
vice president kabal harris addressed
the nation during the celebrating
america event on wednesday night
a great experiment takes great
determination the will to do the work
and then the wisdom to keep refining
keep tinkering keep perfecting
the same determination is being realized
in america today
as former president trump left
washington he signed off on more than
140 new pardons and sentence
commutations
included on that list two las vegas
famed sports bettor and developer billy
walters had his sentence for insider
trading commuted
walters was convicted of insider trading
back in 2017.
he served part of a five-year sentence
in prison but was serving the rest of it
at home because of the coronavirus
walters also paid more than 44 million
dollars in fines forfeitures and
restitution
he's considered one of the most
successful sports bettors in las vegas
history
telemarketer kyle komodo also had his
sentence commuted
he had served six of a 12-year sentence
for scamming more than 30 million
dollars in a telemarketing scheme
komodo faced a 100 million dollar
judgment against his company from the
federal trade commission
next on politics now a message of unity
i think we're having to have a very
united party
coming up what joe biden told us during
one on one interviews in the primary
campaign in the race for the white house
and ufo disclosure is inching closer the
new deadline for the senate to hear a
report on government investigation
how you can put more money in your
pocket
welcome back to politics now
house speaker nancy pelosi plans to send
an article of impeachment against former
president trump to the senate on monday
that launches the start of a senate
trial on one charge of inciting
inner insurrection as part of that
deadly capitol hill riot on january 6th
trial motions have to begin the
following day unless a deal is brokered
to change the date
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
wants pre-trial proceedings to start
january 28th
and that would push back the start time
president biden is no stranger to nevada
he campaigned across the silver state in
his run to the white house
our oracle mana spoke with him three
times last year
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
joe biden is officially the 46th
president of the united states a big
theme of his inauguration day speech
wednesday was unity
a message he shared with me even back in
may during the democratic primaries
i think we're having to have a very
united party
and my message to all and what they're
finding out now that
the nomination process is de facto over
they're finding out the positions i had
an awful lot of things
were not accurately characterized and
and they're feeling more comfortable
with it but i'm listening
i'm here i need them and i hope they all
will join us and now president biden is
hoping supporters of donald trump will
join him including republican lawmakers
of course one of the biggest challenges
requiring collaboration
is how to handle the covet 19 pandemic
and its devastating effect on the
economy
in my interview with him in october
president biden pledged to provide
more federal support there's money there
to make sure we should be
providing extended unemployment benefits
we should be making sure those small
businesses are going out of business
have the ability to stay open have the
ability to sanitize have the
ability to test and trace have the
ability to bring in customers
with some confidence president biden has
also set an ambitious goal he has
promised to get 100 million doses of the
covet 19 vaccine into the arms of
americans
during his first 100 days in office
orcomanna 8 news now
you can watch the previous interviews
with now president biden on 8newsnow.com
just look for the political news tab
president biden's team now includes
former state senator from here in nevada
ivana kinsella
she's working in the office of health
and human services canceller was a
democrat in district 10 that's east of
the strip
includes part of the mccarran
international airport area
clark county commissioners now have 19
applicants for that open seat and they
include former democratic state party
chairwoman adriano martinez
former regent lisa levine and melissa
clary who ran for las vegas city council
in 2019
and has also worked for the u.s
department of veteran affairs
there's also an open seat in the state
assembly democratic assemblyman alex
assefa has resigned
recently metro police recommended
criminal charges against decepha
in a campaign finance scandal he has not
been charged
applications to fill that seat which is
district 42 are due tuesday at noon
to be considered you have to be a
registered democrat and live in the
spring valley area here in las vegas
government investigations into ufos
we're asking the u s government to
engage in something that historically
had never wanted to engage in
up next the new timeline for the senate
to get a report on those investigations
and what's expected in the report
now you're watching
politics now the clock is ticking for
the pentagon's
hush program to investigate ufos it's
called the uap
task force and it's been ordered to
prepare a detailed overview of the ufo
mystery for submission to congress
the items george knapp has new
information about problems faced by the
task force
as a race is to meet its deadline the
first public mention of the uap
task force came in june 2020 when the
senate intelligence committee formally
asked the pentagon
for a comprehensive analysis of the ufo
mystery
over the previous three years members
and staff of key committees had received
closed-door briefings about startling
encounters between the u.s military
and unidentified aerial phenomena uaps
the senate intelligence chairman marco
rubio acknowledged to mystery wire
that lawmakers consider this to be a
serious matter this is a very simple
equation for me
there are things flying over our
military installations
we don't know what they are or where
they're they're from we don't know
some other country that's doing it and
we need to know the answer to that
question
simple in august 2020 the pentagon
formally announced the creation of the
task force
and in late december the massive bill
containing government funding and covet
relief was signed into law
as first reported by blogger danny silva
a provision in the bill
authorized the task force to prepare a
comprehensive analysis
of the ufo mystery and submit it to
congress within 180 days meaning around
june first
getting a straight story out of the
pentagon about its interest in ufos has
always been a challenge and the same is
true of the uap
task force for one thing it's not
exactly a new creation
veteran intelligence officer lou
elizondo spent years as the program
manager for atep the pentagon's previous
ufo investigation
when the new york times first revealed
the existence of atip
in december 2017 the pentagon said the
program
ended in 2012 and that it didn't really
have anything to do with ufos
neither claim was true elizondo said the
program
never ended it continued even after he
left the government
as a loose confederation of personnel in
different parts of the national security
apparatus
elements of that investigation formed
the basis of the newly named uap
task force members of the public and
media excited about the scheduled report
to congress
might want to temper their expectations
because there are significant barriers
to anything
resembling full disclosure for one thing
the report to congress will be
unclassified meaning it will not contain
the most sensitive
most classified cases or incidents
because those directly involve
national security key committees will
likely receive separate annex reports
regarding classified incidents that
information isn't likely to be made
public
secondly while the funding bill ordered
the task force to produce a
comprehensive analysis
of the uap mystery it provided no
funding
the task force was not provided with an
actual budget
only marching orders mysterywire asked
the pentagon to comment on this but
received no reply
thirdly sources familiar with the task
force say there's been a major
change at the top the high-ranking
official who's led the ufo investigation
for years
is out the name has not been made public
but we've learned it's the same official
who's been briefing congress since 2018
and who's been directly responsible for
getting elected officials
interested in the subject the navy
assigned the official to other duties
can the task force finish its job by
june 1st
maybe not it's a gigantic undertaking to
search the entire national security
system
for all relevant videos and files and
then to seek input and analysis from
other intelligence agencies
it is entirely possible the task force
will have to ask congress for more time
in a radio interview in late december
lou elizondo announced he has left to
the stars academy
the company which coaxed him into coming
forward in 2017
also departed is veteran intelligence
official chris mellon
both men say they're still supportive of
ttsa
but are now largely focused on behind
the scenes work in washington
to encourage congress and the pentagon
to move the ufo ball down the field
elizondo cautioned the public to lower
its expectations about the task force
report
saying quote this is a process not an
event we're asking the u s government to
engage in something
that historically had never wanted to
engage in i think a lot of people have
these false hopes
that disclosure is here and all of a
sudden have this huge announcement by
the u s
government progress is being made
elizondo says
the task force report will be just the
beginning he hopes congress will
authorize a permanent uap
program one that has a budget and the
authority to truly investigate
a perplexing mystery for mystery wire
george knapp
reporting now on a related note the
founder of the to the stars academy
rockstar tom de long
said they have some major ufo related
film projects that will be announced in
2020
welcome back to politics now president
joe biden says he plans to review the
trump administration's downsizing of two
national monuments here in the southwest
the boundaries redrawn in 2017 for bears
ears and the grand staircase escalante
are both in southern utah
the president says president biden he is
re-examining the monument's role
as part of his plan to fight climate
change
this week in what to watch the state of
north las vegas
mayor john lee will have his state of
the city address wednesday at 10 o'clock
in the morning
mayor lee says he will outline his idea
the horizon for the city
and coronavirus efforts it'll be
streamed on the city's facebook and
youtube pages
plus two members of the state
legislature need to uh be filled two
seats anyway by the clark county
commission
both are democratic seats we are waiting
to see who clark county will choose
to replace ivana kinsella and alex
assefa in the assembly
uh don't forget the uh legislative
session starts
on february 1st and coming up next week
here on politics now we'll take a look
at the state senate speak with lawmakers
there about what they are expecting
in the legislative session up in carson
city certainly a lot on their plate this
year
i've also watched to see in washington
dc about a possible impeachment hearing
and a trial
in the senate as well so a lot to watch
as we look ahead to next week
that's all for us this week here on
politics now thank you very much for
watching
all the political news you need is on
eight newsnow dot com
we'll see you next saturday
you